Let's do some more word
problems. And this first one's
a bit of a classic.
Brit has $2.25 in nickels
and dimes.
If she has 40 coins in total,
how many of each
coin does she have?
So let's define some
variables here.
Let's let n equal the number
of nickels she has.
And let d is equal to the
number of dimes she has.
So let's see, the first thing we
know is that she has $2.25
in nickels and dimes.
So how much money
does she have?
Well, if you take the number
of nickels, each nickel is
worth $0.05.
So the number of nickels times
0.05, that's how much money
her nickels represent,
plus the amount of
money her dimes represent.
So she's got d dimes.
They're each worth 0.1 of a
dollar, or .10, or 0.10 if we
want to put the 0 in front
of the decimal.
So this is the total amount
of money she has.
If she has 5 nickels, you'd do
5 times $0.05, it'd be $0.25.
If she had 4 dimes, that'd be
$0.40, and you would add it
all together.
Now, the problem tells us that
the total amount of money she
has is $2.25.
So this the first statement
right there can be translated
into this equation right here.
She has a certain number
of nickels and a
certain number of dimes.
You multiply $0.05 times the
nickels, plus $0.10 times the
number of dimes, you
end up with 225.
Now, this second statement,
she has 40 coins in total.
And I'm assuming that she only
has nickels and dimes, that
there aren't any other coins.
So 40 coins in total, that
means that the number of
nickels plus the number of dimes
has to be equal to 40.
So the nickels plus the dimes
has got to be equal to 40.
That's what that information
tells us.
Now, we have two equations with
two unknowns, and there's
two ways we can do this.
We can do this as a system,
and we can subtract one
equation from the other.
Or we can do substitution.
Let's do substitution.
That's often a more intuitive
way to do it.
So what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to solve for-- I
could solve for either one-- but
I want to solve for-- I'll
solve for d and then I'll
substitute whatever I get for
the d in this equation
right here.
So if we subtract n from both
sides of this equation-- so
let me do that.
Negative n plus this, minus n.
Obviously, these cancel out and
you're just left with d is
equal to 40 minus n.
Now, we can take this.
We just established using the
second equation, using this
second statement, that d is
equal to 40 minus the number
of nickels.
And we can use that to
substitute back in for d.
So this first equation will
now become 0.05 times our
number of nickels, plus 0.--
I'll just write 0.1-- times
our number of dimes.
We already know that the
number of dimes is
equal to 40 minus n.
That's what that second
statement told us.
So instead of d, I'm going to
substitute it with 40 minus n.
40-- that's the number of dimes
we have. It's 40 minus
the number of nickels, and
that is equal to $2.25.
And now we can just try
to solve for n.
So we get a 0.05n plus .1
times 40, that is 4.
Let me show you that I'm
distributing it.
So .1 times 40, that is 4 minus
0.1n-- I just distribute
this times each of these terms--
is equal to $2.25.
And then what can we do?
Well, we can take .05 minus .1--
or your .10, depending on
how you want to do it-- if you
take those two terms, you're
actually going to get a negative
0.05n minus .10--
this is twice as big as that,
so it's going to get a
negative number-- plus 4--
so I still have that
4-- is equal to $2.25.
Now I can subtract 4 from both
sides of this equation.
I get negative 0.05n is equal
to-- if you subtract 4 from
the left, that 4's going to go
away-- you subtract 4 over
here; 2.25 minus 4-- that's
negative 1.75.
All right.
Now we can multiply both sides
of this equation by negative
1, just to make it a little bit
cleaner, so that becomes a
plus and a plus.
And then divide both
sides by .05.
I could have just divided both
sides by negative .05 to begin
with, but I like getting
everything positive.
So if you divided by 0.05, you
get n is equal to $1.75
divided by 0.05.
So let's do this division.
Let me do it in a
different color.
0.05 divided into $1.75--
let's multiply both the
divisor and the dividend
by 100.
So we're going to go over two
decimal spaces, so this just
becomes a 5.
This becomes 175.
This is the same thing
as 175 divided by 5.
5 goes into 17 three times.
3 times 5 is 15.
17 minus 15 is 2.
Bring down the 5.
25.
5 goes into 25 five times.
5 times 5 is 25.
You have no remainder.
So this is equal to 35.
So n is equal to 35, and now we
can solve for d. d is equal
to 40 minus n.
So d is equal to 40 minus
35, which is equal to 5.
So we have 5 dimes
and 35 nickels.
And just to verify that that
actually does make sense, 35
nickels are going to
be worth how much?
Well 35 times 5 cents is
going to get us to
175 cents or $1.75.
So this times 35, that is going
to be $1.75 in nickels.
35 times 5 or times .05,
depending on how you
want to view it.
And then this is
going to be 5.
So this right here is going
to be $0.50 in dimes.
$1.75 plus $0.50,
that's $2.25.
Let's do one more.
A pattern of squares is
out together-- oh.
out together as shown.
I guess they're hanging out.
How many squares are in
the 12th diagram?
So let's see what's happening.
So this is the first, that is
the second, that is the third.
Let's see here, each side, this
is a 1 by 1 square, and
then here it's 2 by 2, but then
they take out this block
right over there.
So let's see.
So one way you could think about
it is this is 2 by 2,
and this is a 3 by 3, but they
took out the 2 by 2.
And so the next one is going to
be a 4 by 4 where they took
out the 3 by 3.
So I guess one way that we can
describe the number of
squares-- actually, the easiest
way, you don't have to
think about that is, look, I
have 3 here, and then I have 3
minus 1 over here.
Let me do that in a
different color.
3 minus 1 over here.
Here I have 2, and here
I have 2 minus 1.
And then here I have 1, and then
here I have 1 minus 1.
I have nothing.
So in general, the number of
squares for any n is going to
be n plus, then we
have n minus 1.
Plus n minus 1, which is the
same thing as 2n minus 1.
And it works, right.
2n minus 1.
2 times 3 minus 1 is 5.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So works for these three.
So the 12th square, so when n is
equal to 12, it's going to
be 2 times 12 minus 1, which is
equal to 24 minus 1, which
is equal to 23 squares
in the 12th diagram.
Actually, I said lets do only
one, let's do another one.
We're in the zone.
Grace starts biking at
12 miles per hour.
1 hour later, Dan starts biking
at 15 miles per hour.
Following the same route, how
long will it take him to catch
up with Grace?
So let t equal the time
Grace is biking.
Actually, let me
do it this way.
Let me do it the time
Dan is biking.
Then how long will
Grace be biking?
Well, he starts an hour-- let's
see, did I say, yeah--
an hour later, he starts.
So whatever number this is,
Grace is going to be biking
for 1 more hour.
So t plus 1 is equal to
time Grace is biking.
When this is 0 this
is going to be 1.
She will have already been
biking for 1 hour.
And we just have to remember
that distance is equal to rate
times time.
So Dan's distance is going to
be equal to 15 miles an hour
times the time in hours.
This is Dan's distance.
And then Grace's distance--
maybe I'll call that g, or
let's say D for Grace, that's
her distance as well-- is
going to be equal to
12 miles an hour.
And her time in terms of t
is going to be t plus 1.
She's going to be always
be traveling for 1
more hour than Dan.
12 times t plus 1.
And the point at which they
catch up, that's the point at
which these two things are
going to be equal to.
That Dan's distance
is going to be
equal to Grace's distance.
So we just have to set these two
to be equal to each other.
So you get 15t is going to be
equal to-- that is how far Dan
has been riding his bike-- and
then it's going to be equal to
12 times t plus 1.
That is how far Grace
has ridden her bike.
And remember, her time is always
going to be 1 hour more
than Dan's.
So let's just solve for time.
So we get 15t is equal
to 12t plus 1.
12t plus 1.
And then if we subtract 12--
I'm sorry, 12t plus 12-- I
don't want to make
a mistake there.
If we subtract 12t from
both sides, you get
3t is equal to 12.
Divide both sides by 3-- let me
scroll down a little bit--
you get t is equal to 4.
So after 4 hours, after Dan has
been riding for 4 hours,
he will catch up with Grace.
This is Dan, and if Dan's ridden
for 4 hours, Grace has
been riding for 6 hours.
6 hours is how far Grace
has ridden for.
And Dan after 4 hours,
4 times 15, he would
have gone 60 miles.
And Grace after-- sorry, there's
1 more, this isn't a
six-- she goes 1 more
hour than Dan.
So it's 5, she's traveled
for 5 hours.
So Grace would have gone 5 hours
at 12 miles an hour.
And that, once again,
is also 60 miles.
So they meet at exactly
the 60 mile mark.